DONALD TRUMP: The United
States will withdraw
from the Paris Climate Accord.
I was elected to represent
the citizens of Pittsburgh,
not Paris.
Pittsburgh?
Now what was upsetting about
that, and that alliteration,
was the stereotype of our past.
But Pittsburgh is
poised and ready to lead
in the 21st century.
WOMAN 1: We're seeing cities,
and states, and companies,
and individuals saying,
we are still in,
even with the president pulling
us out of one of the most
important treaties when
every other major country
in the world has said, we are
gonna come together and commit
to dealing with climate change.
CHRIS CASTRO: I
continue to be shocked
at how close the water has being
encroaching just on the beach.
Sea level rise is completely
apparent in Miami.
FRANK VANCE: We
had six and a half
foot of water on the main level
of the house for over a week.
Stuff that was in
our bedroom wound up
in the garage, and stuff
that was in the garage--
I imagine that's way
down in Louisiana now.
ARTURO MASSOL DEYA:
The storms are becoming
stronger in Puerto Rico.
The worst thing is to think
that that reality will repeat.
STACY HYATT: Not a lot survived
that fire in Ventura County.
It burned so hot that
everything just liquefied.
To not be able to
save anything--
it was just really hard.
MICHAEL MANN: If we're
going to avoid breaching
catastrophic levels
of warming, we
need to be putting our foot
on the renewable energy
acceleration pedal.
The transformation towards
a renewable energy future
is the greatest
economic opportunity
of the 21st century.
RHEA SUH: Businesses
have lined up to say,
we're still committing
to the Paris Accord
because it's good for
their bottom line.
DAN LUTAT: My daughter, Faith--
she made the decision that wind
was where she wanted to be.
This is an opportunity
that hasn't
been available in America
for a long, long time.
DAVID ANDRADE:
The solar industry
is offering that
second-chance opportunity
to individuals like myself.
CARLOS CURBELO: It
doesn't matter if you're
a Republican,
Democrat, independent--
you have a role to play here.
BILL PEDUTO: And if we
look at it as an American
Marshall Plan, we can exceed the
goals of the Paris agreement.
PROTESTER: This
is the start of us
taking control of our future.
WOMAN 2: We have the
right to a future.
We have the right to
these basic necessities
that we need to live.
We, the people,
need to take action.
Our lives are at stake here.